all right exciting stuff bring in
another
mukbang Into The
Ether this one has quite a bit of fun
empty
words to play
on
so the very first thing here is
no
one and that is that no
one is hearing these words no one is
saying these words no one is watching
this
stream it's already empty and whole and
free and
Indescribable and unconditional
and no
knowing it's not something that is
[Music]
known there's no
entity so there's no one that could
know
and there may be something that comes up
about using a map to get to a
place and it just
happens it's not that there's someone
inside that
knows and because there's no entity
because there's no one there's no coming
or
going that means there wasn't a birth
and there won't be a death nothing ever
came nothing ever
went it's just boundless like the
sky like the wind like the
water
already great comment in the live chat
also who cares exactly there's no one to
care
so write on in the live chat much
love the
[Music]
free that it already
is it's just what is is already free
anything that's appearing is already
free these words are free this listening
is
free this water bottle is
free
this body is free that body is free
everything is already free it's just
Freedom appearing as words and as
listening so it's already
free and there's no one that is
registering
it there's no one that's knowing it
there's no entity that came and then
goes it's already just Freedom just
simple Freedom appearing that's
it absolute appearing here we go here we
are
simple no ground no
conclusion how could there be a ground
if there's no one if there's no entity
if there's just free
how could there be a ground or a
conclusion everything is just what is
what is doesn't have a
conclusion now within that appearance of
what is there can be
that that seeking energy is looking
under every single Rock for for what it
already
is
and there can be a very
blunt response of the body that nothing
is
lost that it's already
Checkmate and it's already
free without
a
position without
correcting it's just a response of the
body of unconditional love and
freedom to itself with itself it's just
a
response it's like the
dog the bird
flying the ant crawling
it's all that which is
this it's not a position it's not a
correction only someone would still
correct because there would be
ignorance that is seen that needs to be
corrected but what's being said here is
that it's Freedom appearing as seeking
and
asking
what I'm not
whole that that's Freedom appearing
saying
that
the wildness is very
spontaneous it's beautiful it's free
it's
natural it's just like
nature it's all already
nature there's a no one inside
nature nature is no one
everything there's no entities inside
nature it's just
nature so no entities come and go it's
always already no one although there is
an appearance of a body that is born and
then that
passes the whole time it's no
one the whole time it's non-local it's
everywhere
everything can't not be that it can
appear to be lost and
lacking but it's not possible to ever
leave what you
are which is
this already
checkmate
already
Checkmate
everything is Checkmate
already nothing is not Checkmate
everything is Checkmate every word is
Checkmate every movement is
Checkmate not a single thing is not it
everything is it everything is
it including the appearance of
oh I'm not
it I'm lost I'm unho I
lack I'm not
free that's it too everything's
it there's nowhere to go with already
Checkmate there's nowhere to
go it's it's already no
one it's already the
whole it's already
spontaneous just like
nature without a center without a doer
without an entity without a
controller it's all just
spontaneous
Dow
freedom
flow naked and
light no
one
naked naked like that baby that dog that
cat like
animals before clothes and
names and locations and all other kinds
of
conditioning just that pure innocent
nakedness which is
lightness there's nothing heavy there's
nothing
solid there's nothing
serious it's all just
light it's all just
light nature is
light the absolute is
light can't not be
light
it can appear as heavy and serious
and
[Music]
clothed
hiding not being
vulnerable it can appear as all of that
but it's still
freedom it's still light it's still
utter innocence and nakedness
appearing
as
that so it's always no one it's always
not an entity it's never been an entity
it can never be an
entity it's always and forever not an
entity always and forever not an entity
always and forever the whole always and
forever everything always and forever
nothing and it's so
free it can appear as something as an
entity
as I'm not it it's so free that it can
appear as I'm not
it but it's impossible to
leave it's always it it's impossible to
leave it's always
it empty empty words empty empty
listening blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah
[Music]
wow simple
wow wow to the apparent technology
enabling
this WOW to the apparent
buildings that this is being listened
broadcasted from and
listened to
within wow to the
water wow to the
food wow to the
body
what an incredible apparent
vehicle
Wow Wow to every sight every
sound every
texture every
appearance
whoa
wow
cool
damn
interesting and
Dao
da da in both
ways as the ineffable da
D and as the decentralized autonomous
organization
Dow it's the
air it's no one
everying
it's already
free
da
freedom
d
da
freedom
d
d d D freedom
freedom
unknowing
D
Freedom
unknowing
d
Dow
[Music]
freedom
freom
d
Freedom
freom no
one no
one
nothing Unknowing
no
entities no coming or
going Alpha and
Omega
beginningless
endless
[Music]
freedom
freedom freedom
freedom I am everything that is
appearing the freedom of everything
that's appear
simply what
is is what I
[Music]
am
Freedom impossible to not be
free can't not be
it
always
[Music]
it
no
[Music]
ground no
conclusion no one to
know no
position no
correction
oh there's free
emojis emojis that have the word free on
them very cool live
chat
all is
it
d
d wild
Dow so wild it's everything that's
appearing
fre
already
free so blunt it's already
free
already
Checkmate everything is Checkmate
everything is absolutely
everything
everything everything is
it everything is
it it's all
it no separation no
distance it's all
it
naked
light
Primal
Delight
naked
naked naked
naked wow
wow wow
Dow wow Dow
da when the appearance of a center point
of a me is no longer it is seen by da
that it never
was Da
effortlessly functions
two shepher basic
needs abundance for
all wake up every day basic needs are
met be free be free be
free once the center point the me is is
SE to be an
[Music]
illusion
D fully
effortlessly Shepherds basic needs and
abundance for
all
da
no word yet every
word impossible to say yet every word is
it
Dow will
share that
it updated
its it's patreon
on these links are always in the
description what
silly goon
squad free the
nip Dow me
Daddy
D me
Daddy free the
nip free
thep free
thep goon
squad goon
squad
so join and support if it's
resonant Dow Dow
Dow d
Dow
Dow Dow Dow Dow
d
no
ideas no
knowing
just
this as it
is
no one
home never been anyone home never will
be anyone
home always and forever the
whole always and forever
everything the freedom of
nothing comment in the live chat no
becoming no one to
become
no
entity Freedom Perfection all
ready no
[Music]
becoming
one of the jams that
will
come
out
at some point this is a teaser of skirt
skirt skirt skirt skirting around the
nothingness inside skirt skirt
skirt skirting around the nothingness
inside skirt skirt
skirt of course it's impossible to ever
not be
it but it can appear like it's
just skirting
around the
whole that it
is that bodily contraction of me of a
center
point is the
very inhibition
of
nothing
everything
Freedom lot of apparent suffering and
Stress and Anxiety with the illusion of
being an entity that is becoming and
attaining
wholeness attaining
fulfillment
Dow such a
clown apparent decades and decades and
Decades of looking for what you already
are skirt skirt skirting around that
nothingness
[Music]
inside
d
d d always
already
[Music]
fre appearing as
everything
can't be said yet is every
word impossible to leave yet can appear
as though it's
lost
d
such a clown appearing as separation and
War
empty of ID
is full of
Freedom whole
AF
oh
even still free and empty just
words
the throne that can't be
left
please help me find the chair that I'm
sitting
in
d
there no one
anywhere freedom of not
knowing
the word itself coming from from
nothing being heard by
nothing what could
change
nothing
Freedom
already
can nothing change
can Freedom
change
apparently yet it's always
free
always only
show me what's not
free try to say something that's not
free
always only free
no
one
Nothing
free empty
words
spoken and
heard
hitting
nothing the words can never hit
something
it always hit
nothing
words never hit
something they're never said from
something
they always hit
nothing and they're always set from
nothing in its apparent game of
everything
for
[Music]
nothing just hearing these
words
for in the live chat
[Music]
nowhere
nonlocal no entity no
location nowhere
everywhere the
wind
that water
[Music]
falling where's the center point of the
hydrological
cycle just ucer
boxes ucer conceptual
bounds
[Music]
h
no
ideas
knowing
freedom
the I'm the
da
D nowhere and
everywhere this
appearing is me
can't leave
it impossible to not be
it
forever
most common
question that
this channel receives in the live
chat as if it's
tripping this is the freedom that
is
before
the
illusion of a contracted Center
Point that
then takes
substances to try to find the nothing
that it already
is the trip is the center
point where's the center point in the
hydrological
cycle where is the center point in the
sky where
it's not
there it's not
there this is the non- entiti non
local
innocence it's there with the baby it's
there with the dog or cat or
animal it's not possible to leave
it you just
apparently get
contracted into a me that
lacks and that's still free
appearing as
that
yeah the trip is
on the
nothing that is
everything from the perspective of
me
which is still made of
nothing empty empty words blah blah blah
in heard by
nothing always heard by nothing always
said by
nothing
in a prior
episode there was a bit
on what the
dsm6 the diagnostic and statistical
manual that the world uses for treating
mental disorders
what the sixth version of it would look
like if it came from the perspective of
nothing everything instead of from the
perspective of me and separation and
others and
lack the entire manual is written from
the center
point where is the center point in the
sky where is it in the hydrological
cycle
where
this
is what is
always the me apparently inside outs
itself
to see what it always
was
yes very empty live chat very
free very
whole
everything live
chat canot be ever
everything nothing being
everything
[Music]
or for the illusion of
me not
everything
separate
the love that can't be
left the love that's never
lost the love that no one always
is
no can't leave
me can't
it
so
free
[Music]
h nameless and Timeless is already
all
nothing ever
changed it just appeared
to
nothing was ever
lost or
contracted just appeared
to a solid entity was never
formed it just appeared
to
find me a center point in the sky
then we can talk about the me being
real find me
solidity in the
ocean
we can talk
about entities being
real
all entities are
imaginary Barbie
house
in its own little
[Music]
world playing with dolls with other
names that it can get fulfillment
from
not a Center Point in
sight already and always
free without an
entity
as no one
everything
without someone that
[Music]
knows without anything that comes and
goes the
freedom that already is that is all of
what
is everything arising is always and
already
free empty
words spoken and
heard by
Nothing
free no one no entity no
ground no
conclusion no position no
correction just
free
empty Wild
blunt and always already
Checkmate everything is
Checkmate this is empty this is free
this is Checkmate that is Checkmate
everything is
it naked
totally zero
hiding
light not
serious not
solid not
heavy no one no
entity
wind
all Checkmate all wow
wow
wow and
da
d da
D
Freedom
D I'm the
D
everything
everywhere Unstoppable
freedom freedom never lost
never actually
contracted just appearing to clown with
myself as war and
others absolute
[Music]
freedom
d
total and complete
Freedom everything is
possible no
entities no
knowing never come never
go never
anyone
all
right wrapping up the
mukbang thanks for
joining I
shared this a little bit earlier also I
updated
the the patreon page to make it look
more beautiful
and
fun with the up-to-date
frequency goon
squad goon goon goons goon goon goons
[Music]
Squad free free free free free free
free and free the nip free free the nip
free it free the nip free
it furry it furry the
nip free the nip free it free the
nip and D me
Daddy Dow me Daddy D me
Daddy if it
resonates
support takes a
village to
da
and free bodies of basic
needs let's
[Music]
go dance
party you
know
yeah yeah a little bit of dance party to
wrap it all up little bit of dance wrap
it all up yeah it's free it's free it's
free not known by anyone just free free
free free free free free free free free
free free already free free free free
free no entity free free free free free
free free free free every single word is
it free free free free all of these
words are it no saying it no hearing it
everything is it everything is
it bye-bye
m